excellent
excellent ah I actually saw the opening
sequence
okay what the
[__] what the [__] helpy you son of a
[__] what the [__] is that what you
meant by scy hi huh okay um hi welcome
back to Five Nights at Freddy's help
wanted it's been a little bit I know but
don't worry because today we're going to
finish this I was actually planning
going back here anyway but I think that
on the
ceiling means this ride and I almost did
it perfectly before keep your hand I
almost did it or end them like me so it
must be something to
do with helpie and all the little helies
get out of there and I don't necessarily
know what exactly I was supposed to do
differently except to be a little better
right oh oh oh oh nope the other way yes
please come
on I got to be cool like this you know
actually I don't know if I got that
first helpie before I'm not exactly sure
if I did that from the beginning so
maybe that's what I missed from the
get-go maybe I got everything else but I
just so happened to miss that one be
reced that he St on the improved
R oh I must not have because I don't
think he said that before I don't think
I saw this this
early
ah so somehow from the very beginning I
missed that first helpie oh my God hey
no thank you
okay all
right who waa why do it get why do it
why does it go dark like
that hello oh god oh no that's not what
you want that's that's what you want so
I need to keep open the ones that are
going to give me the points I need and
close the ones I
don't ah my eye not my eye as in there's
something in my eye I mean my eye is in
my expert aim damn
it I could have gotten two rounds with
that if I hadn't been so bad maybe I
need to stand a little more relaxed who
okay I got that one before I know I did
that this is how I've seen Olympic
Shooters
[Music]
do feels more stable and more relaxed
anyway probably cooler right I look
cooler don't I elix isn't that don't I
look
cool yeah be not responsible for any
Mings that might happen on this airpod
uh I just got got to be on the lookout
for dude
McMahon so long as I can beat down dude
McMahon I should be all right oh
boy there we
go did I did I not get him all oh I did
okay help
me whoa
helpy oh helpie did I miss a helpie no
oh some of these objects are a little
too VR wonder if I take off my mask if
that would do
[Music]
anything of
those oh my yes okay I've got 10,000
that just means I need to finish it out
and the real treasure was
FR
yippe y yippe I did it oh man I did it
okay that was closer than I thought
11,000 I think that's
everything okay whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoo
whoo
oh oh my God wait wait stop
okay oh oh thank you for
that okay thank you thank you at least
this happens at the end of the level so
I know that I did it
okay all
right a beautiful high score and we're
good to go mini DJ music man all right
okay so
that's it right yes yes there you are
all right oh no help he's dead Okay so
that just leaves this one
so trying to remember what I was doing
last time so new tasks available check
the computer I don't know about that big
helpie Funtime fredbear fun man fredster
okay there's another office one there
there's that there I've done the fazer
blast I have not done the DJ music Pro
fizzy night 5 hold
on
okay it's all always in the
clue it's a clue right it tells me
exactly what I need to know there's a
tombstone that says no power what
levels would have no power and has
saroni what levels even control the
power where am I facing I don't even
know anymore what has
power and can have have not the power
what do the power what do the not power
what has power but then no power and
rest in peace that might just be a
Genero you know oh it's a graveyard kind
of thing which is entirely possible but
I'm willing to believe that there's
something going on here with a sodon and
no power now there's
sodon right there and there's definitely
sodon in that because this is is
soda
so oh o o o ooh Idea Idea Idea Idea Idea
Idea okay let me just hang on W Idea
Idea Idea Idea Idea Idea I have an idea
you oh
God ah
[__] oh I don't like
that yeah I don't like
it good God okay all right I
thought I had the idea that it what I
needed to do was actually
make
sodon oh good God okay all right you
know
o because if there was a way to make
sodon then there would be something for
me to do after
that maybe maybe I I kill the
power does this count as no
power so I can put this in
here and that that has to mean something
because there's a sodon right there and
there's something about no
power but there's nothing in it what if
I just put the sodon in and send that
off
damn oh uh chica don't do that whatever
you're doing don't do that uh
stop
hi hello yeah
hi uh-huh you know I haven't gotten a
special order from you guys in a while
okay well do not fail make this do not
fail okay well I you know I was just
saying how I didn't have a special order
uh I'm I'm going to fail
uh oh boy uh well all right so ha you
can't oh God my pause button didn't
work I thought I I thought I pressed the
pause button that has to be it it's the
only place
where there's a
sodon it just so happens to be there
there's technically a mechanism that can
do power with the lock down each of
these had to be in a certain version of
the game so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go into this and I'm going to
look at every version and make sure that
there isn't something that I'm missing
because there could be something else
that I'm
missing
besides the obvious so if I were to put
this in here that's in there now put
well I guess I don't have that put this
in here oh it's only got three did it
really start out with only three take
that okay so that's not it what happens
when I lock down I can't even lock down
in this one there's nothing in the
garbage there might be something in the
garbage is there a clue is there some
kind of
information some kind of clue in the
environment anybody got an environmental
clue clue clue clue clue clue so I can't
lock down here I'm I'm willing to bet if
it had to be something it's going to be
something like that and I don't think
that there's going to be any kind of uh
I don't remember I don't really remember
anything actually being different
between these levels but let me go to
the next one see if there's something
different yeah I I wish it like said on
it what it needed so now you have four
ingredient opportunities I go like this
I put that in
there so I can't even put all of these
in
there okay so I can do the
power whoa what is that is that actually
a thing is that a crumpled recipe damn
okay whatever chica is not even there
you're not there you're not there so I
can't even
put five 2 three four five I've got to
get to the part where I can see six
I've got to get to the point where I
can when five could hold on one second
cuz my beted
is it's got to be something where I put
one of everything in right that's
probably how you make the sodon right no
it can only do
five hold
on go go go go go go
go
damn it okay all right
um there's got to be a clue there's got
to be a clue so chica's here does chica
have any indication dumping ingredients
May attract unwanted pests dumping it
maybe I have to dump it do I have to
dump it do I have to dump it to crump it
is that what I need to
do
dump oh uh well that just threw it away
didn't it oh God she's up okay so that
didn't do it that didn't help at all cuz
like in the certain night in Sister
location that was the only night that
the keypad was open the only one I
haven't done is
three work is fulfilling and you are
happy today is that
true okay clock and job start now yeah I
know I know clock in job start now I
have this you have this you have that
you have this chica is here you do this
put this h h h h
hey oh what in the
freak
what why did it work there what's the
difference between here and there what
what's the difference okay we got to we
got to win this now we got to win this
now go go go go go okay I am am out of
everything please go please go faster
please I really need to go oh boy this
is not going to go well all right you go
you take a break you you go go oh God oh
God no okay I can I can miss this one
okay I hope the next one needs protein
okay you take a
break okay you go faster you go faster
you go faster you're going to take a
break next fiend fiend sugar sugar sugar
oh
crap oh crap I goofed that really hard
God okay I can take that one I forgot
that there was protein in there that's
my
bad okay sugar acid acid protein
caffeine in there you take a break you
go faster we need caffeine so we need
you back up and running I will not
forget to turn that out no one else is
in this room besides me me I don't know
why that worked boom I'm just going to
Chuck it anyway we need caffeine you can
take a break we need morphine please not
more fiend but more wo hi bud okay yeah
yeah yeah don't worry don't worry okay
protein we're fine actually I don't know
why I didn't give you a break protein
acid acid caffeine sugar in what do we
need always fi take a break okay protein
protein acid acid suar in bam haven't
had many visitors
today that's who hey oh God return to
work same time tomorrow you got it all
right so that was actually a lot easier
than I thought it would
be hello what do I got soda that is
topical that is weirdly topical so by
process of elimination I figured that
one out it was kind of dumb and I think
that's all of them
right do I get anything for that was
that just happy fun times was that just
to get oh oh
whoa
whoa what do I do with
this well I still have
it oh God come get your candy here candy
candy fan fan
wait a minute oh oh oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait insert
coin oh yeah
oh oh did that
oh oh oh
god well I don't like that I've never
played an arcade cabinet game in VR but
here we go oh God you are one and you
remain uh-huh what is left that is
hidden uh-huh now go to next
room okie
dokie what does this do I think it's a
wao what the
[Music]
freak I don't know what this
does oh it's a Teleport okay
oh
[Music]
aha what is this feeling I don't know
what is
[Music]
feeling oh God oh God don't don't get in
my way bunnies or I kill you I kill you
I I thought I kill you oh my god
really oh my god really okay this is
unwieldy oh
boy okay
okay that doesn't make any
sense okay at least they're giving me
more Hearts it is uh oddly very
difficult to
[Music]
control okay I swung and it didn't work
there's like a delay on the swing don't
blame
me oh
god oh shoot ah God it's so easy to go
too
far
okay oh God it's so easy to just my God
this is viscerally annoying and I got to
be really dainty about my attacks cuz or
my presses because super easy to press
the wrong
button oh I wonder where this goes I
don't
[Music]
no okay all
right okay God damn you oh what why why
am I go rft you freaking
thing oh my
[Music]
God okay oh look at that wait a minute
this isn't oh Jesus hi don't stab me
don't do
it oh my god
oh
huh I don't know what that was about H
my vision oh oh oh
hi take it oh ooh oh I get to play
now uh whoa hi
um uh kid all right don't worry about me
oh all right wish me luck princess
you now you're going to get
it take that I wish I could just
move I wish I could just
locomote take that man this is a lot
scarier in first person not not
no yes you shall be vanquished by
me you shall be destroyed
yes that's what I thought give give to
me I'll take that I already took
it that is fun actually this is kind of
fun I'm into this I like uh VR hacking
slashes they're kind of cool sometimes
the controls aren't what you want them
to but this one actually is pretty
nice I said be
ignited
excellent die by my hand by my
sword yep thank you I will take that I
took
it what beasts lurks in this
layer what horrible foul demon d try to
stop me hello what are you doing down
there get dead can I have you oh I see
you think you could hide from me no the
answer is no I would cut thy throat in
Twain but I'm a good dude what was that
all right whatever I see you hold on
murder is incoming be ready murder
approach es
shut I see you down there shall ye be
murdered
yes that's what I thought oh look murder
occurs
ow well I had to let them get a hit in
once I'm going to hit my hand on my
room ow oh wait a minute that wasn't
supposed to
happen
anybody anybody else H
peekaboo oh yeah Bring it on Bring it
on right in the
eye that's what I
thought
girl
yeah ow wait what the heck what the
heck ah I
see uh chica I doth Knight thy grave and
Freddy thy grave is illuminated and uh
well golden Freddy I think Freddy
regular Freddy
Bonnie and then we've got the puppet who
cares and then foxy what happened to
yours lit
[Music]
uh-huh is this a
code are these codes am I supposed to
remember
this cuz it's like gemstones am I
supposed to remember that maybe
not Hello King prepare to
die hello old man
oh oh it is a fair trade wa what oh god
oh God what is that oh
God what is
that what is oh oh it's the
elevator oh oh W who what the whoa whoa
hey wait a minute hey wait hey hey wait
a
minute why are you so
big how do you get so big naughty
naughty well okay
that's oh my
god
oh
hi oh
[Music]
oh see you around
vany
oh
what
huh wait wait hold on wait a minute I
didn't but I didn't do all the
games I didn't think that I was get I I
didn't think that that but I didn't do
all the games I didn't do all the
[Applause]
games
[Music]
oh
wow um all right cool well
Y yippe what did I
get
VY I suppose and where did VY even come
from like what what game did VY start
with was it uh was it security
whoa hi it's a little lunis honest but
you know okay all right then well that
was good I guess I beat it um why are
you facing me I don't like that I don't
like
that uh-huh so there are still some
secrets that I have not
obtained and there are still some mini
games that I have not
beaten and also where's
my where's my last dude where' my last
dude
go where my last dude go
so I'm going to leave this one here I
thought we were going to finish it all
but apparently I jumped the gun and I I
bet I got the true ending for some
reason or something um but hey you know
what at least we've got I'm never going
to find you I went the wrong way there
we
go vanie all right
so that's
great that's
good that's that's
good cool good to know I wonder if V's
going to make an appearance in the
sequel movie
sequel probably anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching uh we got
one more to go apparently cuz we got
some Secret that I did not quite obtain
so I will definitely get to that very
very
soon have a good day everybody I'll be
back and I swear this movie I've been
working on is almost done just a little
bit
longer then things will be back to
normal
eventually